Lastly, let's discuss some basic
descriptive statistics concepts.
In short, descriptive statistics provide
simple summaries of a data sample.
Examples could be calculating an average
GPA for applicants to a school, or
calculating the batting average of
a professional baseball player.
In our electricity supply scenario,
we can use descriptive statistics to
calculate the average temperature
per hour, per day or per date.
Some of the commonly used
descriptive statistics are Mean,
Median, Mode, Standard Deviation and
Interquartile Range.
Udacity has an entire course
dedicated to descriptive statistics.
Which I encourage you to look at if you
are unfamiliar with these terms and
concepts.